[Musique]
bon
et ça va être un peu compliqué car il ya
une double traduction ce que je dis en
français va être traduit en anglais puis
en géorgien
donc je vais essayer de tenir en 15
minutes et j'espère que la succession
des traductions sera bonne donc je viens
d'une ville qui s'appelle bordeaux pour
voiliers qui dans le sud ouest de la
france
alors j'ai un diplôme de sciences
politiques et j'ai un doctorat de
philosophie que j'ai obtenu à paris à la
sorbonne et donc dans ma vie privée je
n'imaginais absolument pas travailler
j'ai d'ailleurs élevé mes quatre enfants
jusqu'au moment où ils sont partis à
l'université et où ils sont entrés dans
le monde du travail et je n'étais
évidemment encore moins j'étais encore
moins préparés à travailler dans le
domaine de l'urbanisme puisque je n'ai
absolument aucune compétence pour faire
ça néanmoins je fais ça depuis 20 ans ou
22 ans à côté d'un homme qui s'appelle
alain juppé qui a été premier ministre
de la france ministre des affaires
étrangères et qui est maire de bordeaux
bordeaux étant la sixième ville de
france depuis maintenant 22 ans
je voudrais vous montrer en 14 minutes
comment à mon avis et je pense qu'alain
juppé partage cette idée j'espère que
dans la salle il ya beaucoup de
personnes qui partagent cette idée
je suis absolument convaincu qu'il n'ya
pas de fatalité historique et qu'il n'y
a pas de déterminisme historique
je suis absolument convaincu que
l'énergie des hommes elle peut contrer
elle peut bloquer l'inertie le
conservatisme des structures et c'est ce
que je vais essayer de vous montrer lors
je vais maintenant je ne vais plus
parler de moi je vais parler de bordeaux
parce que c'est quand même la ville que
je connais le mieux
en vous montrant comment elle a changé
en 20 ans alors en 1995 bordeaux sa
première caractéristique c'est qu'elle
est pauvre et qu'elle est très endettée
elle est pauvre parce qu'il ya cent
mille habitants qui l'ont quitté pour
aller habiter en périurbain à
l'extérieur parce que c'était plus
confortable et elle est très endettés
parce qu'elle a elle s'est lancée dans
une série d'investissements très
important et qui ne sont qu ils n'ont
pas été productif c'est à dire que c'est
investi
ce moment non pas créer de richesses
deuxième caractéristique de bordeaux il
ya vingt ans elle est sale elle est sale
et dans le centre historique
je devrais pas le dire mais les
habitants sortent et leurs ordures sans
même les mettre dans des sacs en
plastique troisième caractéristique de
bordeaux il ya vingt ans elle était
complètement asphyxiés par les voitures
pour une raison simple c'est que les
cent mille personnes qui étaient partis
habiter à l'extérieur revenez quand même
tous les jours travailler avec leur
voiture et qu'on avait pas un système de
transport en commun efficace et donc
dernière caractéristique de bordeaux il
ya 20 ans tous les gens qui avaient du
talent les étudiants qui sortent de
l'université les jeunes entrepreneurs
les artistes m'a tout seul à quitter
bordeaux pour partir à paris bien sûr
l'eldorado ou pour essayer de réussir à
l'étranger
aujourd'hui 20 ans après voyez comment
les 100000 habitants sont partis pour
aller vivre en dehors de bordeaux
aujourd'hui 20 ans après qu'est ce qui
se passe
premièrement nous avons réussi à
éliminer à nous débarrasser des voitures
nous avons réussi à nous en débarrasser
parce que nous avons réalisé un système
de transport en commun avec des tramways
très performant nous avons aujourd'hui
77 km de tramway mais nous avons aussi
des bus très efficace nous avons aussi
une politique en faveur des vélos qui
est remarquable et nous sommes devenus
la première ville cyclable française
nous avons un plan piétons que nous
sommes en train de développer et nous
avons également des batobus puisque nous
avons un très grand fleuve qui s'appelle
la garonne voilà le tramway qui
circulent sur le pont de pierre et vous
voyez qu'il n'a pas de caténaires voilà
un parking à vélos liées à la politique
de transports en commun nous avons
développé une politique d' espaces
publics très efficace vous retenez
quatre règles là où le tramway passe les
voitures ne passent pas seul le tramway
traverse la ville historique
les voitures elle elle contourne la
ville donc il ya plus de voitures dans
le centre historique
troisième règle quand on refait une
place ou quand le tramway arrive on
refait intégralement l'espace public de
façade à façade on refait le sol on
refait l'éclairage public ont refait le
mobilier urbain ont refait tout
et 4e règle tout note dans tous nos
espaces publics nous considérons que 50%
de l'espace est réservé aux piétons et
aux vélos deuxième qualité aujourd'hui
de bordeaux elle est propre
évidemment une ville n'est jamais
complètement propre mais enfin nous
avons réussi à pratiquer le tri sélectif
une chose extraordinairement difficile
pour nous les français
troisième caractéristique nous avons
regagné 40 mille habitants entre 40 et
45 mille habitants et nous comptons bien
d'ici 2030 avoir regagné les 100000
habitants que nous avions perdu bordeaux
métropole ces huit cent mille habitants
aujourd'hui quatrième point remarquable
en 2007 nous avons été classés au
patrimoine mondial de l'humanité par
l'unesco
et nous sommes le plus grand ensemble
urbain classé au monde
en fait vous voyez le périmètre ici à
droite le périmètre est cernée par le
trait rouge et la zone tampon par le
trait jaune c'est presque toute la ville
de bordeaux qui est classé au patrimoine
mondial
voilà quelques exemples de bordeaux la
place de la bourse qui le le plus grand
ensemble patrimonial le plus connu et
puis dernières conclusions de ces vingt
années de travaux tous azimuts c'est
qu'aujourd'hui la ville de bordeaux
c'est peut-être un peu exagéré mais elle
recueille un nombre de labels de
distinction absolument extraordinaire
j'en retiendrai 4 en 2015 nous avons été
qualifiés par un grand organisme la
ville du bonheur en 2016
nous avons été reconnus comme la ville
de france préféré par les salariés ça
veut dire que les gens qui travaillent
en france en un seul rêve c'est venir
travailler à bordeaux il n'y a pas du
travail pour tout le monde
troisième distinction remarquable en
2017 l'homme dit planète nous a désignés
comme la meilleure destination
touristique au monde et il ya deux
semaines nous venons d'être reconnue
comme la ville la moins stressante de
france tout ça est très exagéré mais ça
veut quand même dire quelque chose sûre
c'est que devenu bordeaux alors je vous
montre quelques photos avant après
juste pour que vous compreniez là la
différence assez les bords de la garonne
avant aujourd'hui
avant il y avait des voitures partout
aujourd'hui la mairie avant la place
aujourd'hui
voilà une petite place avant et
aujourd'hui une autre place avant et
aujourd'hui il y en a des centaines ça
c'est la place de l'opéra avant et la
place de l'opéra aujourd'hui alors
comment a t'on fait pour en arriver là
du côté du politique il faut retenir
trois ou quatre idées mais pas plus la
première idée c'est que on a eu un homme
politique qui s'appelle alain juppé et
qui était un homme politique avec une
très grande
oram nationale et internationale et pour
obtenir la confiance des habitants c'est
important d'avoir un politique qui soit
connu
2e deuxième élément obligatoire cet
homme politique il avait une vision
il avait une vision pour bordeaux il
avait une vision à moyen et long terme
et cette vision elle s'est exprimée par
des projets urbains alors je suis très
fier car c'est moi qui les ai rédigé
pour alain juppé ces projets urbains ils
ont été communiqués et partager avec les
habitants
le premier c'est 1996 le deuxième 2009
le 3ème 2013
et aujourd'hui je prépare le projet
metropolitan 2030 2050 je serais morte
quand il sera réalisé
je suis quand même très content d'y
participer troisième élément important
c'est la stabilité
alain juppé et mer avec des petites
interruption depuis 22 ans à bordeaux ce
n'est pas une condition suffisante
évidemment pour changer une ville mais
c'est une condition nécessaire si vous
avez une instabilité politique
vous ne pouvez pas mener un projet
politique sur le long terme
dernière condition c'est que il faut que
les investisseurs qu'il ya une logique
dans les investissements opérationnels
je prends un exemple très clair en 1995
le merdy la priorité pour moi c'est le
tramway et les espaces publics
c'est le
la restauration des équipements de
proximité c'est à dire les écoles les
gymnases les résidences pour personnes
âgées etc et le patrimoine
on met tout ça en oeuvre ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire que très vite dans
l'espace public
il ya à nouveau du confort il ya à
nouveau de la place comme il ya de la
place les commerces développe il ya des
bistrots qui arrive ya des événements
culturels qui arrive dans l'espace
public
et comme en même temps on refait les
écoles les gymnases les habitants qui
étaient partis habiter à l'extérieur se
disent on peut revenir parce qu'on a des
équipements efficace et on a à nouveau
la capacité de respirer dans cette ville
et comme en même temps on s'occupait du
patrimoine les touristes ont dit on peut
revenir
le patrimoine est en bon état on a de
l'espace public dans lequel on peut se
promener
il y en a des transports en commun qui
nous évite de venir en voiture et c'est
comme ça qu'on est entré dans un cercle
vertueux et que ses effets cumulatifs
ont déclenché de l'emploi et on
rapportait de la richesse et c'est comme
ça qu'on est sortis en fait de la
situation très difficile de bordeaux
alors de l'autre côté du côté la société
civile qu'est ce qui s'est passé
évidemment il ya quatre mots clés pour
la société civile le premier c'est la
confiance
le deuxième c'est lé projet partagé le
troisième à mon avis c'est l'horizon
temporel
il faut qu'on soit capable de penser
avec un horizon précis et puis le
dernier c'est le récit collectif alors
la confiance elle est arrivé assez vite
elle est arrivée d alain juppé a dit
j'ai un projet pour ma ville
et voilà qu'elle est mon projet la suite
de quoi quand l'administration et le
politique ont proposé à la société
civile d'entrer dans des partenariats la
société civile à accepter quand je dis
société civile se sont l'université
les commerçants les promoteurs
immobiliers les banques les
investisseurs et le fait d'entrer dans
des projets communs avec
l'administration
évidemment à augmenter la confiance du
côté des habitants ce qui crée la
confiance c'est lorsqu'ils voient que
les projets annoncés se réalise au bout
de 4 ans 5 ans 10 ans le tramway rouler
les espaces publics été refait et
évidemment les habitants à ce moment-là
apporte un capital de confiance aux
politiques troisième
chose le récit partager le récit
partager comment vous expliquez ça ça
fait 22 ans que il ya des projets à
bordeaux un grand projet politique et
donc au bout de 20 ans ont fini par
partager une histoire commune avec les
habitants on partage une histoire
commune
on partage des projets communs et donc
ce qui se passe c'est que aujourd'hui on
est sorti de la simple notion de
confiance pour entrer dans l'idée d'un
récit que l'on partage un récit que l'on
partage ça veut dire que nous avons tous
quels que soient nos opinions politiques
nous avons tous aujourd'hui les mêmes
représentations de ce qu'est bordeaux de
ce qu'est la métropole de bordeaux il
nous avons les mêmes représentations de
ce que nous attendons de l'avenir ça
veut dire qu'aujourd'hui on a encore
besoin du politique évidemment mais les
meilleurs ambassadeurs de bordeaux ce
sont les bordelais eux mêmes quels que
soient les difficultés politiques nous
marchons à peu près tous dans le même
sens alors et bbc dans tout ça alors
vous avez plein de points communs avec
bordeaux vous avez la beauté vous avez
une ville incroyablement belle vous avez
un patrimoine absolument extraordinaire
vous avez une situation géographique
stratégique ce que pas du tout le cas de
bordeaux
nous on est simplement à côté de
l'espagne aujourd'hui c'est compliqué et
puis vous avez une très vieille histoire
avec beaucoup comme les vieilles
histoires beaucoup de malheurs et dont
vous avez vraisemblablement une capacité
à la résilience qui est remarquable
aujourd'hui dans le monde contemporain
la résilience est sans doute la qualité
première que l'on attend des sociétés et
des villes parce que le monde va très
vite et donc quand je pense à tbilissi
où je suis venu déjà quatre fois j'ai
l'image qui me vient à l'esprit c'est
l'image dans le film qui s'appelle notre
enfance à tbilissi du petit garçon qui
joue du piano et ce petit garçon
finalement malgré les malheurs de la
guerre il
il réussit à rendre l'impossible
possible nous a bordeaux on a rendu
l'impossible possible et je suis
absolument persuadé qu à tbilissi c'est
ce que vous allez faire et que vous
allez rendre l'impossible possible
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]